[Music]
welcome guys today's lecture and today
I'm gonna be talking about games the
last remaining three games that I
haven't talked I mean last three runs I
haven't talked about from candidates
they were supposed to be two lectures
but we'll make one but much longer and
big one and this will be grandmasters
choice and games of the week combined
meaning that I want to go in much detail
from into the gains from candidates
because I think they are so important
that it's really worth to basically
analyze them and I was thinking that my
kind of like analysis would be very hard
to put interesting and to shed some
light on the what could have been
happening in both games and so on after
the analysis with engines and like a
human eye so let's just start it and the
last time we stopped the analysis on the
game of Maxim holograph versus versus
Alexander Grisha it was round number
four and MVL had great chance to win
this game and here unfortunately for him
he squandered his chance and they given
in a drop but and the last time also I
want to talk about next game fifth game
but we basically run out of time so
today we're gonna catch up with this and
basically talked about all like rounds
at games from one a one game from around
fifth sixth and seventh from round
number five I chose the game of Vianney
policy versus Wang Hao Wang Hao I mean
work out shows a very solid opening
which is petrov and
very good opening obviously and but the
only policy prepared very interesting
idea and he managed to trick his
opponent into mr. move orders and like
drive the position I mean they enter
basically cyber endgame and he wanted in
sort of alpha zero style so let's see
what happened before if 593 nine f6
Knight xe5 and right now
Napo in 2019 he played in World Team
Championships in 2019 against you young
people at d4 he warned his game very
nicely as well so if you haven't seen
this game I encourage everyone just look
at it but this time he prepared
different idea Knight takes e5 Knight d6
9 f3 Knight takes e4 d 4 other
possibilities plane se free here which
Napa house had played many many times
this consider things the main sort of
try versus the trough but in this game
he said play d4 personally I've tried 93
I've tried Knight of 3 and T 4 in the
past I also played here d4 possibly back
is fine everywhere so basically you just
have to play against opening a spectrum
which was you try to find some openings
it's some lines for one or two games and
this is what basically everyone is doing
and neppo is not an example not another
exception every game something else and
in this one you prepared this from this
line Knight takes e4 d4 d5 Bishop d3
which are by 5 and this is very real
popular system recently because with
this move order black tries to avoid
some lines that white can go for but
Knight the knight c6 has been considered
for many many years as the strongest
response but after after short Castle we
should be 7c for 9 before and they're
basically line goes
Bishop e2 I think I don't remember
exactly how it goes half English above
five Knight c3 short Castle a free maybe
I'm mixing move orders but I think this
is the line and this this has been
tested for many many years back is in
general fine but there is a new trend
here at nine IBD to personally I tried
many times those Knight c3 with
relatively good results more like I
think all my games and even then draw
even though I had good position and
chances to win for instance I played in
Bundesliga in two thousand thirteen or
fourteen versus Constantine lambda and I
had a winning position but it was I
messed up when it was a draw eventually
but recently there have been 92 trend
here and I think white may have some
chances for an advantage so Bishop f5
here sort of prepares egg on this 92
line that hoping for some better version
or slash move order to get those
positions behind
- and it has drawbacks because right now
it's possible to play let's say short
castle we should be seven there are
moves like 95 which has been tested in
the past and that for instance our son
degree she played several times and also
rare Robson wand again again in design
versus Riku Zubov also Knight c3 is
possible here at the 95 also see for
their many many moves here and I will
dive into a deep analysis right off
Petrov but I really like the approach
that nipple here employed in this game
so let's focus here the Ruby one a short
castle at night bit 92 earlier they play
Knight c3 Knight xt3 B takes c3
takes takes we've generally good results
but it seems like too many pieces are
being traded immediately and it may not
be so dangerous with correct play for
for black so he played second time in a
row
I think second Kay
maybe he played more about like in this
like on top top grand master level 92
second or he played 96 the problem right
now with the special benefactors you can
tell retain because visually the five is
just big big problem
[Music]
yeah is your favorite games from
candidates yeah this is very good game
and very instructive as well so 96 and
now 93 never played against Duda in 2019
in vikon's i-93 c6 Bishop before Knight
Bishop takes the frequent xD free and
the game was not if for rookie - never
was started better for majority of the
game let's see what happens inside a six
hook a 197 seems like very logical to
bring this i-26
therefore we have to take it most likely
takes 92 we should be forced he free
takes takes we should be 695 g6 and the
group Queen h3 Ruby - and I think this
position with study better for it simply
because White has control over the
e-file there are some ideas may be
playing g4 preparing at some point but
acting is a little bit vulnerable I
think their idea sleeping at 395 maybe
g3f for maybe between the Queen
somewhere to f3 at some point create
some threads may be pretty frequent f6
there are lots of ideas here for wide
overall black has no chance to win it
and it looks like slightly better
position simply but here when I was
analyzing this game I found some
improvement of 97 which is reasonable
novelty because why to play 94 when you
can just develop your piece instead and
the you can develop your piece instead
on the server does not to be 7 doing
this the same job because 95 could have
been a threat and night Bob Knight e4
and 97 prevents this 95 expansion so
97 Rudy - Rudy a look a ones above 8
also 94 could be possible but I like
fate and I'm not very sure whether here
there white has black head I mean black
has any problems here or if white can
have any pressure because like nice if I
was covered and if we try just one pair
of ropes the I don't think there would
any problems for for black also be short
XD 6 we can take only to take on g6 done
and this seems design won't be free a
little bit misplaced a map in it should
be on f1 rather than on be free that's
why nappa in this game against one cow
decided to play Knight of 1 and it makes
perfect sense Bishop takes the frequent
XD free c6 Bishop f4 96 against similar
idea innate 796 and right now an epic
aim of the novelty or move h4 and this
is very interesting novelty because
again sort of alpha 0 style because
officer used to play like it for any in
any position simply and after in this
position it creates basically several
ideas one of the ideas is basically the
25 it give takes under control g5 Square
and allows scientific code 95 another
function of this h4 movies to play basic
h5 h6 maybe or if after h5 it by decide
to play h6 then square and a5 could be
potential weakness if we can get this
night here eliminated is not even get
our 912 5 for instance so and the third
idea could be so nice to play Bishop g5
not really sure how great would it be
but it basically create some a quiz a
king side expansion where white can
create maybe some sort of attack on the
King side so it proves some weaknesses
create some practical difficulties for
black objectively I don't think it gives
an advantage we have correct play but
because on the other hand if you think
about it why would it be so great like
black has dual reeow with any weaknesses
but and it's complete symmetry nearly
complete symmetry like only if I always
open
it looks like exchange friends and
exchange French is basically like nearly
that draw 0-0 at least
but here there are some chances and this
h4 move very often with like sort of
modern chess like of a zero comes of a
basically a position here is other like
in such a dry position he even here h4
give some possibilities to make the game
interesting so Knight c7 play it with
one cow and now Knight g5 and here is
the first question what how to react to
this night midnight on g5 because we
determines as a threat and there are
basically two possible reactions map in
either to take on g5 instabilities what
work how did because I think the most
human approach that you could that could
ever be could be could be here because
after mistletoe hd5 we eliminate the
knight on d5 which is creating some
danger we also simplified the position
as black and we want to we quicker get
two best players the Queen 78 and try to
basically trade rooks and trade some
pieces trade quiz hopefully and
eliminate all the attacking material
from white and just make it roll like
that
which for mark how I mean as he was
playing with black and such determines
candidate is definitely definitely a
good result so 95 and and now yeah we
should h5 one option a second option is
g6 and g6 is possibly better move but on
the other hand it contains some risk
simply to put simple in this way after
g6 there are more pieces on the board
King is a little bit weekend because
darts per around the King are weekend
for instance after g6 93 there could be
a sea of 94 and this night could do some
damage there and I'm for instance I know
Queen d7 looks logical to prevent night
94 but then what can proceed with h5
suddenly
this king is a little bit uneasy on on
g8 f6 could be met by nan h7 sometimes
I'm not not really sure whether it's so
great position for four black possibly
this move correctly but to decide to go
for it in practical game it's not not so
easy
alpha zeros edge friday story taking
over in top says yes that's really
really true how to pronounce my name my
name dario church in polish if you want
to say it so here rook e8 a for-instance
night the three you can come back and
basically bring this Knight to e5
because i don't you v did its own job is
a good job and provoked some weaknesses
now was then comes to come back to e5
their ideas big beefy see for us well
maybe rookie to Wragge one maybe rook 81
and then b3 c for many many ideas very
out of this dry position from petrov or
like similarly to exchange frank
suddenly there are some ideas here for
worried and not sure i'm not saying that
they are like so strong and they give
advantage but definitely there there is
something to think about for for black
and if especially not expecting this
this line which for his idea is not easy
to to react over the board that's why
the simple radical radical reaction and
solution to this problem 9 g5 is built
HD 5 just simplify the position which
makes perfect sense and he goes well how
goes for a very solid set up with queen
d8 a queen the queen 7 and rook e8 we
showed the HD 5 of 6 HD HD 5 I don't
really like I don't really see a point
of this 96 could be a simple problem
here immediately
King on the for helium g5 mission to HD
5 f6 Bishop a4 and 27 and now a wide
black this was fun cause idea to play
basically next move rook a e8 in this
position I was
when I was writing this I was thinking
that Napa made like small mistake here
because he played move Knight g3 and in
general in such positions where it's so
little already material to start with
and position so symmetrical there are no
any clear weaknesses that would block
and I would have what can exploit or
black has to defend are sort of sort of
so you should try to keep more pieces on
the board just to create more and more
ideas and here 93 was played by nappa
and I didn't really like this move
because the energy free has much less
possibilities in the further future
rather than on e3 because from e3 it can
go to a five and g4 as well and but the
most important thing supports c4 and
maybe hits on d5 at some point and
another thing it doesn't trade rooks yet
because prices after night g3 rook e8
could be was played already and we
should take the six sort of force okay
well it basically afternoon difficult
just transpose the same thing but after
ninety three if let's say I played g6
and prevent Knight a5 and there is
nowhere a follow-up go through the
design on g3 and the next move 88 and we
can block and just trade drugs I don't
really see how what what can do here for
instance I analyzed h5 King f7 and again
I don't see what white would do next
let's say next move is rook e8 trying to
trade all the rocks play 96 then this
night has no entrance this night has no
entrance here has own entrance here has
no entrance here doesn't support the CC
for break floor in the center so this 93
is what plays only if it gets to a 5
let's say but if it doesn't get to f5 it
seems like it's just stupid in there so
that's really reason why I think that
more accurate move was that if
and after the idea is that after Luke a8
first of all we can take on d6 and 95
and it's exactly the same thing that
happen in the game on top of this there
is a possibility to play rupee two and
we can just play rook AE 1 prepare
basically maybe taking on d6 it's some
position that we you know it's
unplayable position because keeping
grooves on the board gives wide more
possibilities to create something really
dangerous for for for the for the future
let's say attack on the in the center or
on the kingside whatever white planet
choose it's more flexible after 93 as I
said g6 would be a big problem for
instance after 93 if I play and here g6
here already ok this will be the same
thing after which the 86 quiddity we
don't have either 5 years it's the same
story but we have we can have for
instance some sometimes 9g for both also
we support let's say B 3 and C 4 who
died only a few doesn't really do
anything so this is the small difference
small / big difference between both -
Night Moves
was after ng free Rocko played the most
primitive and natural rook e8 but if you
played g6 first I think he position
which is equal because I don't see what
why does next if Y doesn't do anything
concrete right now after okay yet we
just trade all the rooks and there will
be no animating attack or like a
possible attack for the future for to
create for for white and going back
night the phone ID freeze if there is
just waste of time we shall be free
looks also weird so I don't really see a
plan here for for white so this will be
just equal in my opinion but how return
the favor
I played rook e8 and right now we
transpose finally to this game take
neither 527 and right now
Queen h3 hitting the
the Queen non-disadvantaged six tactical
idea and this is what I think Napa was
had planned in his preparation to the
game I'm pretty sure that he had this
analyzed or something similar some
similar positions where eventually gets
to a5 and positions are basically you
know playable because even though they
are symmetrical I don't know if I was
much more active than I don't see seven
and they creates some potential threats
h5 is coming and it's not so easy with
black to play still black should be able
to equalize and in fact black can
equalize here as the for analysis
suggests which I did but on the other
hand is not easy over the board so here
work how does I'm taking a trade which
is the most let's say natural move
because Knight h6 let's say if some
Reynolds like a 690 cheese which means
the Queen but he's talking edge edge
just runs away with the king from this
this idea however it is putting this
King on a trade in very unfortunate
Square because right now there will be
always some issues with the back rank
and black will never get to kick this
knife from a five as well because of the
King h8 h 5 and G 6 is now never an
option it's never possible because of
this pin on the edge file just it just
takes H 36 and wide widths so this King
thinking it is most natural move but
it's not correct the correct move is was
rook is 6 and this very hard move in my
opinion to play but the idea is very
very important in a very sound as well
because the right now g6 follows and
there is no way to stop this move and I
think right now black can equalize if
only this night from f5 can be kicked
out and also Ruby 6 has additional idea
of playing rocky 8 and maybe trying to
fight for the e-file so Robeson was very
from move that would have equalized in
this in this game and analyzed sim
following lines for it says h5 looks
very natural to try to prevent g6 but g6
works anyway nothing says 9h 16g 794 and
right now
Queeny 8 and apparently there is nothing
that there are no really
any tactics for instance if king f4 it's
a root X is sick just quit X is 6 HD HD
6 after HD HD 6 there could be if I
think about right now some of like h5 if
I'm mistaken this could be just
perfectly ok
like HT 6 other I'm going depth with
this but I think h5 looks perfectly okay
because the problem is after takes we
can play Queen h6 with white and this
seems to be just really bad but if I go
h5 suddenly after Queen to h5 rugae J
the Queen is trapped so that if she's
only to save the queen
and if not this then we have to go now
if free for instance and just take
stakes contagious is just equal position
so this this detail might have might
have run away from my house oh no this
is over the board which again is very
hard to place a move like age 5 and
after King f1 we can already grab this
pawn and suddenly position becomes very
very unclear yes that is on a 5 is very
sermonette 500 but on the other hand
black exponent so it's debatable who who
is in whose favor is this position black
can play let's play Queen g4 at some
point rook e8 maybe trade ropes and if
we tried everything sternly like would
be left with pawn up in the endgame so
position because remains very very
unclear
another possibility is truck tech see
six here after Queen Texas six then h 5g
six and now take take any value H six
there is just King g7 no any issues and
if Queen g3 analyst Queen takes a
five-point xt7 rook F seven and again
this position seems very very close to a
draw still as micro see is required but
it's possible to do it because after
Queen B 8 King g7 rook e1 we don't care
about this policy too because all what
mines activity let's say we play C free
a rupee seven I think would be a problem
because then Ruby to becoming or Quincy
to becoming an activity I think black
has perfect position on the other hand
white can start with rook e1 and after
quintic C to just play G free and make
sure that the words can be save and
prepare okay this will be very very
tactical and I'm clear however in my
opinion a black can just play a g5 here
and this should be perfectly okay for
from Black Francis rook e8 and now
quindi walking to Queen takes before I
don't think what has anything more than
just perpetual with Ruby Jade okay trade
for instance there's this and just
Quincy 828 would be just draw I don't
think there's anything more than four
for white and I draw here
yes Oh Ruby says was very strong move
which would basically solve all the
opening problems but it was very hard
especially with this line with h5g 696
the 94 Queen yet as I can also very hard
move to play only like in us as I found
it when I was analyzing preparing this
game to to show today and after takes
takes is 85 mph also basically you have
to see sort of when you are going for
this line so it wasn't easy but Ruby C's
was indeed the best the best to move and
the best way to solve opening problems
after King gate right finally h5 it
becomes really really unpleasant for
black because the rupee one rupee one
rupee 8 root I see it even night XC 8
and here in this position it seems like
at first at first time white black has
no weaknesses simply position looks
completely ok a4 for black because you
know no weaknesses all the ropes traded
only Queens and knights on the board
seems like just you know one or two
moves like bring the King at some point
maybe just play 96 at some point
something like this and should be just
equal and you know will be a draw
however in this position because the
scheme on a jade is in kind of like
caged if I can pull like this because it
can escape from to GA because my
logistics still is a problem and Knight
d6 could be always met by night XD
seasoned Queen c8 and some puckering
issues and the 97 doesn't really help of
getting rid of the 911 5 suddenly why
White has some pressure here that it's
not so easy for black to face and in
this position I think I think I made a
mistake because he played g4 and this
this move usually very typical basically
supporting line on a 5 3 in the Queen to
basically Drago Queen a free and stuff
this move
I'm pretty sure that Napo had planned
after 96 Quinny free
this was visit from pressure was his
idea
let's save 96 right now could be made
back when a free lift that takes the
[ __ ] whenever I'd made so this could
have been his idea but g4 has this
drawback that this diagonal is not is
now covered in snot opened and the black
can finally start from of its King and
with King create for instance suddenly
I'm not sure what with white doing next
because Jesus is coming
finally I just is not doesn't mean the
Queen anymore in g6 would be just free
move King design the lines from a5 and
not sure what what white would do next
for instance I know as g5 for the screen
G features g6 kicking the night and no
problems 93 96 just equal and if g5 we
can't obviously take on g5 because night
h6 just to show it quickly wide wins but
just Queen f7 and suddenly I'm not sure
what is white follow up here like it's I
don't know he's hanging on g5 white has
to defend its de-spawn somehow and g6
doesn't work because takes takes Queen
g6 just made with check on to the king
in g1 so this tactics doesn't work and
if a four we can just play 97 maybe
prepare Queen e6 maybe 96 why I don't
know why white would be better here and
see a reason for white to be any better
here if anything this entire plan with
g4 g 5 and the 4 is only weakening
White's King which could be exposed in
the future and doesn't really cause any
harm to White's King led to blacks King
I mean but the position is just equal
I'm not saying black is better here but
I think in positions equal and in
general I think that this was a mistake
g4 because of the scheme g8 move and
everybody's following logistics
therefore having said that I also want
to wonder what could be
correct play and plan for for white
because clearly why this better it's
hard to make a next month with white it
was black the second jet again i th 696
queen a3 could be always on @ x d6
and and here I just thought what after
such moves like sorry here a for there
is a rule if you watch some other videos
of mine about and gains its in the
endgame for instance I was talking about
creating second weakness and here is the
perfect example again of creating a
second weakness on the basically Queen
side right now because the first weekend
is the some you know issues on a king
side but second weakness could while
will want to create on a queen side and
make try to make blacks defense harder
in that way for instance after a fight
seemingly the most natural white can
play baby c3 and before suddenly pawn on
a5 could become a weakness and
potentially in the future if let's say
before and like some random moves like I
know it's hard to make be even so just
move because I say h6 you never want to
play King J is impossible there's still
issues in the background might be Quincy
eight or something Quincy was supposed
to say these days these days for
instance and then some moves like maybe
Queenie free could be equally
problematic for instance pollinate five
could be a weakness as well in the
future also 97 could be already some
idea trying to go after season a five
pawns and thread Queens
it's not easy it's not definitely not
easy position so if you just play slowly
just play see free before then create
second weakness and I think this was
correct approach here don't do not rush
of g4 and you know suddenly
weakening actually your own King it's
way different approach than what Nepali
and actually his approach worked really
well actually very well in the game he
was even very beautiful game but from
the academic perspective a for was
correct move in my opinion for instance
Queen e6 just King f1
nothing very hot
just covering the entrance on e 2 and E
1 and not sure again what I scheme Jane
at age 6 and juicing is not possible 96
96 just winds at 7 you are not really
helping with the design of 5 so Queen f7
maybe I thought but then you can just
play a 5 you can maybe play 93 prepare
some you know Queens Theatre something
then 93 96 on the other end so it's not
so easy but maybe you can prepare just
you can maybe just play 85 and suddenly
wide to gain some space 2.7 could be a
weakness it's not so easy anymore but
yes that's what I thought I thought that
I for would be really good tracking for
wide and I think what it's not cheap
either
after G for the Warka had this great
opportunity to save the game sort of
echo and equalize with King g8 but he
didn't do it
he played 86 which is also okay because
again there's no easy way to followup
with White's plate because 23 was an
idea here Queenie free is an idea and to
go for his queen f8 and queen a7 tricks
but I think just being on protects one
protect is creating 3.23 right now King
Jane's possible and hanging and right
now an apple switch to be freed and see
for Plan B 3 Queen six night if free and
in here even though black is fine
because 9 if we fans I had to come back
to e3 and and c4 is a plan of course but
with pollen g4 White's King is a little
bit in danger this may be one in danger
with the wrong choice of words
but it's a little bit exposing some
lines and without I only five blacks
King has some freedom basically to move
back with a king g8 at some point and
here one whole plate 96 which is again
the most let's say natural reply Black
Snow White Knight comes
from comes from leaves at five square
and the night before our cows night
comes to d6 but in my opinion this was a
little bit inaccurate and again the all
the problems that happened later in this
game was were because white white
created pressure on the back rank and on
blacks King therefore [ __ ] how my parent
had to play King g8 here after King g8
if just you know make sure a king is
safe and then you can bring the knight
but the most important piece it just is
king after all because if you get mated
if you know no matter how many much
material you have able to lose the game
so if you seem to make sure a king it's
type of country eight and king f7 bring
this kick a little bit the center closer
and making sure that there are no any
background issues would would basically
solve all the problems membrane for
instance if c4 already detective or busy
for p5 could be possible also Queenie
for is possible and it's not not clear
position because wild basically because
really 175 sensitivity 565 96 black can
turn eventually batter here because King
on Japan could be also a problem if at
some point and I'm here are now as I say
g5f the HD v Queen c8 and there is some
analysis going on Queenie 794 h6 and I
think that white is not worse obviously
but the black should let's say be okay
here for instance 5 qh 7 95 96 and here
i came up the conclusion that there is
just such possible because then she sees
queen you want check always you can
never go for this and if 96 doesn't
really work then you have specific i
what what else would you do here before
it and see any other plan than 96 or
queen f5 and the queen of 5 is just
drawn so possibly will just end and draw
other possibilities to play b5 here this
considering see what goes here c4
b5 let's say d5 and the same position 96
coming
I don't see why what would be so great
about wise position
well I'm with Paul on g4 and close this
diagonal white cannot go Queen d7 for
instance so having said that before is
very often helpful but but not always
the Queen G free would be out
alternative after Queen g3 26 and this
is also important idea after Queen 96
this Queen d6 maneuver is never
available but here pinch 326 basically
just trying to cut the diagonal and this
is just you know solving all the
problems then we can even play that
seven night of night ecigs if we want
but we can also let's say Queen f3 just
come back when he six and then in 96
looks completely okay as well and yeah
so Kim G was much was more cautious 96
shouldn't be so bad either but this
after this move there are some practical
problems for blacks suddenly that
eventually even how didn't manage to
solve and Napo one beautiful game here
h6 very very very good decision -
restaurant move because if GTA's h6 then
quint x h6 this pole the pole structure
is completely messed up for black and I
think there would be black would be in
trouble there and both basically forces
g6 but after g6 pollen h6 is a source of
all kind of problems for for for black
because there are always issues with
let's say back rank and let's say right
now also seventh rank because if the
Queen comes to c7 will be some Queen c7
mating ideas and so on so this point and
h6 causes lots of problems practical
problems for back
and again see for a very dynamic play a
very strong play and the it's not easy
again to react to this such move like c4
you don't want to take on c4 twice
because then I mean you can do it but
after Knight takes e4 for instance there
will be some issues connected with for
instance taking taking and some move
like win a free loops restrung or queen
you freak whenever your queen e3 and
peace queen kind of got the guess to the
whites blacks came in my opinion
whenever is possible on Queen e7 or
innovate also even also there is move
like Queen g3 which is even stronger I
think I'm not very sure I didn't there
I'm going to detailed analysis of this
position but it's becoming great trick
friends also this and Queen h2 would be
very tricky move because after Queen
Geoffrey would be Quincey wait Queen G
free let's say here would be Quincey 1
and black is fine but before play Queen
h2 cavity pwnage discovered Quimby
equation are very important ideas to to
face and I think white will have great
chances to win it and additionally
and you know you if you don't take out
c4 will you basically kind of like allow
take on d5 and pound if I would be a
weakness for instance King g8 steak
suffice takes d5 Queen f3 this would be
basically white with the pawn on d5 and
2 but to be honest ok 94 is to save this
pawn between a 4 and right now
Queen B L is a big problem and if 96 is
the passive defense right now again what
is driving like has driver's seat
because after if a 4 is not easy again
with black to come up with with moves
yes you can play king f7 King G 7 but
what next you are not kind of like
helping out too much of this for
instructor king of a cup a g5 trying to
weaken even more blacks position there
it's my 94 black king is in danger point
96 it puts lots of problems practical
problems and the pressure is definitely
increasing here therefore I was figured
Queen d6 would be the best chance to
solve the problems in this position and
giving this pawn and trying to defend
position with pond ping-pong down but on
the other hand from track perspective
why to give the pawn and of course
computer analysis and normally it should
not be I mean over the but when you
think about during the game you don't
see a reason why to give the pawn
normally so if you give the pawn yes
there would be a problem I mean like if
you consider this as something that
signalizes some problems in your
position and normally you don't want to
give the pawn so it's very hard for a
practical point of view decision to just
get upon and try to defend this desk
type of endgame so there's lots of
psychological issues for for black to
face here rather you know seeing goes
and so on for instance after King King J
was possibly the best defense but
detective or also like does
keeps the material equal so why not be
Texas efore and now again a king g8
again seems like very natural move
finally bring the king in the Queen is
well-placed Knight is well placed so it
seems natural to just bring this night
to the game abdicated King back to the
game but it is a problem right now
because this King is still would be
under pressure after King G gate because
even if it's brass to have 7 right now
it would be under pressure after Queen
h2 because after king of seven c5 this
what happened the game might be five
Queen b8 and Queen comes to b8 and queen
eh I it could be a threat and the
position is very very tricky for for
black and this was that's why this is a
problem
King g8 is the problem of King g8 and
black had much better defense night f7
it's this move basically immediately
attack spawned h6 and stops a move like
Quincy free that's for a starter but the
most important thing that after Queen
trick for your queen h2 they really move
like okay I went across netting such
things possible
pastor Queen h2 there is no Queen d6 so
this is really important idea that
basically queen h2 of the amount of 26
and that this White's King White Queen
doesn't enter you know to be eight or
seven squares that's the basically the
point after night of seven the let's say
c5 just takes control over d6 square
because Queen each two right now could
be a threat but in this end in such
position by force basically 28 again
idea would be very very I mean would be
be very passive and trying to hold onto
the material in such position with such
passive pieces it can be good idea for
instance Queen c7 f5 drinking age three
Queen f6 just g5 and maybe maybe black
can hold this somehow but looks just
awful simply looks awful dispersion
queen of 8f or qing-ge denoise 2797
Windex b7 quintic c5 another such
position and maybe black can hold it
somehow but it's
extremely unpleasant by me at some point
it is black has to just give their piece
anyway it's very dangerous position and
I wouldn't if I had a choice I wouldn't
go for this however quindi 827 and now
queen e8 actually black and cold because
politics is hanging right now it's and
black it stood pawn up for now
and it's not there is nothing but butter
fried here then g5 and after after 85 90
for trying to hold on to this h6 pawn
and now Queenie forb f3 Queenie - and
this list isn't perpetual let's say King
d'Afrique when you want and there is no
way to run escape to escape from this
perpetual f9f - we can already take on
each 6 which basically would lead to
better end game possibly just winning 4
back so white has to accept that draw
here with kimchi free community 1 or
queen jiwon kim ji-won 21 and so on so
it was the best defense night of seven
after kimchi 8 and again the main point
is to prevent Queen h2 26 because after
this position family position it becomes
extremely tricky Queen h2 King f7c 5
king in design out of this d6 square
might be 5 Queen v8 and right now we're
how made the most natural move 27 and
this is already losing move right now
positions just lost after Queen d7 it's
extremely impressive to me because 3/7
looks like you would even sort of think
about okay only 7 is hanging so it just
defend the server and you defend on 7
and at the same time put some pressure
on d4 and keep the pressure on apology
for as well and it seems like the most
natural move but again it's it's losing
move by very concrete means just is a
very concrete game and by very concrete
mrs. McQueen son of it just loses and
here again the best usually not always
but usually the best defense is active
defense and my pin Knight takes d4 was
very strong even though it just gives
the pawn but after Queen b7 Queen 7
Quint exists a 624 and
here honestly I couldn't find how white
could like make progress I analyzed it
quite a bit but I didn't see any way for
white to make a progress simply because
this kink on g1 is a week weekend
because of this pawn g4 his paws on g2
will be perfectly okay which is winning
but apology for that somebody is neither
free nor denied it - at some point and
optimal right now because quill96 but if
the Queen let's say move from Asics
let's say it's somewhere like on h7 for
instance takes Queen b7 say King eight
liquitex h7 and suddenly night e 2 is
already perpetual say king of 193 takes
Queen of three and this is just draw on
activity black can suddenly make a drop
here but yeah it's not easy it's not
easy definitely it's not easy to just
give the pawn just like that and try to
you know escape in such end game
especially when you have such simple so
seemingly defense Queen d7 on the first
thing you know why to even bother with
moves like net is 4 and giving the pawn
some crazy life like after Queen e4
especially there's nothing clear after
that say Queen 7 could be 7 King he ate
queen bee edit shaking of 7 Queen c7
every Queen c7 King yet you know why at
least have perpetual me who has
something more and why do I even bother
of this so for practical perspective it
could be understandable well the other
hand if you feel the danger you would
decide basically to activate your pieces
so this is the that's the point and our
idea was also a kite Queen even Bosman
was extremely hard to play if you have
to choose between Queens and Queen 7
Queen seems much more natural just keeps
more pressure on before his apology for
as well so quittin was extremely hard
enough to play in my opinion but the
difference is after Queen I tried kinky
6 Queen c8
I mean
I mean the same position if Queen under
7 is lost simply because the King has no
square on the 7th after f4 which
happened earlier King D 7 right now is
completely fine for black because King
just escapes and Queens actually
understand doing really you know good
job by crane encounter play it also
predict unit 7 and let's say g5 Knight
takes d4 and it's not so some math 25
some perpetual you know ideas of
Perpetual are in the air and I think
what has here anything as well and if
quiz c8 just Queen d7 and right now this
is better version because right now a
knight XD 4 actually follows and
possibly I'm not sure whether white has
anything better and just Queen g8 Queen
f7 Queen sequence and draw again
so Quinn 7 was the best I mean others
I'm second best move but X from human
perspective it was very very very hard
to play and there could be some ideas
like night c2 here but black should
equal here eventually something like f5
because I see two you don't want to
really go back like this after d5 can
just take simplifies the position again
so we have a second possible defense but
unfortunately for Frank how it like
Queen distance is just lost and in very
beautiful way Queen hid in six and a
four I gave this move to exclamation
marks simply because a5 is coming and
suddenly it's just nearly made in the
middle of the board also as I checked if
I was winning 94 and this also should be
winning because I'm Queen e5 or Queen f6
and this also I couldn't find defense
here but I didn't analyze this too much
because I really like this a form of and
I focused on this because of five just
you know it's killing let's say Knight
if Queen e 7f five kings ranking f2 and
suddenly in this position while AK has
nearly no moves but has nearly no moves
sort of paralysis
because on g6 is hanging at some point
and h7 and just queening also queen bee
it could be possible sometimes just
winning game over
complete domination in here it's hard to
come up the move for black because if
you take on a five I can take the knight
and hitting this for the Queen f7 Queen
B ed is possible or Queen even g7 is
possible it's hard hard hard to come of
the move for back here and after tonight
xD for basically just loses by force a
piece which Nepal plate Queen f7 he
repeated once and the thing is after
King g7 here wasn't actually solving any
problems because of a quit seven can get
queen bee eight and twenty six black
just means the piece that it's not only
for with checks so in Queens happened
the game and after Queen g8 and finally
28 never found the right idea and the
problem is that the 90 talking after
night the for Quincy is just made and
otherwise quinces only move and then to
just a five forces the night go to a
five here and white just means the piece
and this is game over
what's wrong with Queenie seven there is
nothing wrong with Queenie seven I mean
you mean here Queenie seven a queen
seven here this was already lost this
was already lost so but earlier Queenie
seven was possible but anyway this was
extremely hard move to play there was
nothing wrong with but extremely hard
enough to play this is what I was
referring to instead of nine takes d7 I
remember Queen d7 spell it was a blunder
I don't know I'm not sure what what more
you talk about 97 but Queen d7 was a
blunder here and I think the yes Queen 7
was a blunder is a mistake losing
mistake we sell here it's okay
relatively still let's say some game
goes black and white compliance ignites
it to some game goes on
but 94 in my opinion was the best
defense I takes before and basically
called go for activity and whites King
still dangerous but I've believed that
with correctly black can hold it all
right this would be it for this game
let's go with the next one next one I
had prepared is a game of via
nippon-ichi again I mean he played many
interesting in this candidate so far and
this was game I was against Dingley ran
from round number 6 so let's see what
happened before he 500 396 we should be
586 Bishop a4 Knight f6
short castle Bishop e7 d3 d5 Bishop b3
d6 a free Castle Knight c3 Knight a5
recently this is one of the most popular
approaches this line in this position to
his line one I mean the England used to
play also Bishop g4 in previous times
it's very often and
with very good results he made all
drawers I mean made some three if
something sounds fine he made all
drawers in Bishop g4 but you know this
level he didn't have any problems doping
that's what I meant and right now he
switched my date five by some reason
which is I mean this design is also
completely sound wish of a - Bishop e6
and right now White has huge choice I
played myself in 2014 hear Bishop d2
which is possible I was black here I
played this position and Michael Adams
plays played this Bishop g5 here against
me and I played a little bit knackered
Bishop takes a - and here I was lucky
words for majority of the game about the
average damaged called to a drop and
main movie skill c5 and this is the
theory and the black should be okay here
another possibility is visual text is
six and before M Bishop d2 which the
first game in this line was I think car
one versus Iranian in 2014 Singh field
Cup which Fabiano beautifully and ever
after ever since after this game it was
very popular but ever since there were
some developments from blacks
perspective as well other possibility is
deformed which I play against butter
lacquer in 2015 and I managed to lose
this game unfortunately he applied me
very nicely but here the most popular
move by far is before the bishop takes a
to rook takes a - and it's what happened
the game other move is night exit -
which never played himself against with
a shock or
Westley so and recent the recent game of
nappa versus versus Wesley saw was c4
Knight d4 Knight c3 and but Wesson so
didn't have any problems with equalizing
after Knight X I mean c6 maybe should be
three night x f3 Queen takes the
frequency eight bring the screen to e6
h3 Queen six look FC won the here
offered a draw
and was they accepted which sort of
accent understandable because pushing
just roughly equal and so here Napo
decide to play ok 296 Bishop g5 and here
is the first moment were black has some
choice and I don't like Dingley rest
choice to be honest because he played 27
and I'm not a big fan of this move I
believe the best movies give 94 and the
idea is that in comparing to 97 well
here white has additional option of
Bishop III if Bishop d2 basically is the
same thing Knight f6 but after 94
basically the only try here for why did
Bishop d2 mission if you will be just
night XV free and now that f6 is just
you know limits wise choice limb is
white choice to just Bishop d2 and there
is some lines going on there lots of
theory and and via play like some
important games in this also vision
played against West is so very important
game some there's very theoretical
debate about this opening but 27 I never
liked this move ever since I was start
analyzing this line I never liked this
book because of visual types of six
visual takes f6 95 and this night and
the mission if six is sort of problem I
think is is the restricted by its own
pawns white has very simple plan of
playing just see for maybe a four at
some point just expand on the kingside
mean Queen side and bitter policies
doesn't really help there and this this
is theoretical position I want to go
into much details basically are two
moves Bishop d8 or a5 a5 played ignorant
Bishop d8 is another possibility for
instance see 497 and I think this
ambition they could be a little bit more
accurate because here 93 let's say
c6 basically but it's not so not so
clear for instance
should be six then white can play d4
maybe then just maybe I can take it
doesn't seem like it's a lot here for
for white we could be started better but
in the long run black should equalize
also 94 is possible which I think was
the recent game of Motel vs. Tomashevsky
and motor life was much much better but
even she couldn't win another but the
ignorants have play a fight here and
after and here a nap up camera came of
the novelty of rugby - and to be honest
it's I think really interesting novelty
the idea here is that after a 5 rugby -
and the problem is that in this position
we're gonna come back once again in this
position 27 there will be night xf 6 g
f9 h 4 and there black do not have f 5
because what else can take the pawn or
the night and then quincy for basically
let's say take take queen g4 it just
means the pond or we can take off some
of the pony of five which they're about
comedians on the board because right now
let's say f 6 or King h8 and because and
you know game goes on because we can
take this because this lose the piece
and and here is the same idea after a 5
rugby - because after 97 would be takes
takes and the knight age for the same
the same story the same idea the same
problem and here black faces some
unpleasant choice sort of because what
to do next and I think black should play
anyway Bishop d8 and after c4 sorry a
Bab Bishop d8 is what getting the
rounded because the problem is Bishop
did immediately started up front of c4
after c b a c b9 a7 a for this post
fracture gets broken and it's in Poland
before it's very likely to be lost but
still black can hold on to it for a
second 56 let's say BC 96
and let's say queasy to analyze night X
before could be a problem with some move
like Ruby ate at some point I think or
maybe even take on a take on before and
they use up a five Brooksie for verse 85
not very sure but I think there could be
some issues like this and night but
already there are some friends at this
point this is what does the main
conversion that's why we should it is
not another most accurate move the thing
is after a PCA takes before it takes
before Bishop d there are no such issues
because after c4 we don't have to still
take on before but because we already
have took 204 and a Bab is included so
there are no issues with this and right
now this is all correct other
possibility here
yeah and here this is 123 123 is that
here black is two possibilities or 94 or
97 and Dingley run played 94 and I'm not
a big fan of this move usually in my
opinion you should try to keep the
Knights sort of like on the board I
couldn't keep the trade applied on d5
not 9 only 3 or least try to and not you
know to get your point
on 24 because if we were pom-pom guys to
the for their strategic leader could it
could be a little bit challenging
position for black and this is actually
in the game but here if you play 97 we
try to trade the night but still pose
should be started by for white after 93
and you know black can would say prepare
some that say Ruby a it may be done a 5
at some point maybe Ruby eight c6 Bishop
d6
white plan is obviously in d4 at some
point so black should kind of try to
anticipate and react to this I think for
instance I know
h6 could be possible also this this
would be possible but here what would be
better after this with some playable
positions but in general it feels to me
at least the 90 cents more accurate move
but after 94 there were some problems in
this game however ding River indifferent
pretty well and to add up to a point but
anyway there was no really necessity to
go for such such position in here my
opinion if you especially 97 on the
other end yes if the pono is still on
see to this 94 idea makes always perfect
sense but policy for I'm not really sure
it's so great that's just small
clarification
after Quincy - let's say c6 would be
possible neither for Bishop g5 and I
think or p8 I think position would
either way transport to the similar
thing but in Ruby it is a good move that
doing the rim plate you know improving
the rope there is nothing wrong with
this also maybe put some pressure on e4
in case of b c and d c b taxi for the
taxi for pony for will be a little bit
vulnerable so it's good to put some
pressure and if forcing waits for is
already sort of a good thing so napoli
free just i will mention that as I
checked nipple play all those moves
almost instantly so I assume it was all
preparation still be takes c4 and now if
for instance detective or was possible
but it would have led to a very sharp
play for instance c6 Knight f4 Andrew
gave 3 the reston broke a free pole Roxy
free possible maybe Bishop g5 and trying
to key design from f/4 and play d3 it's
getting will get very messy so there was
not really need for this an appropriate
Queen takes e4 is just much better of
course o he'd put the compressor on d4
point in the future c6 Knight a for
Bishop g5 key in the night out
Madrid night it took 9 1992 looks a bit
weird
like awkward and I don't like this 992
it was much more natural especially the
hits on pond d4 d5 it takes d5 takes d5
and this is basically the most important
I mean not the most important but like
one of the most important positions in
this game because here
Napo had to decide where to go where to
retreat with his queen and there are two
options basically their queen bee free
or Queen c2 and the most natural reply
is Quimby free you know queen is
supporting this beep on put some
pressure on d5 doesn't run into the
day-after question - okay c8 moves or
ec8
doesn't run into any of those things but
there are small but here after Queen b3
h v is there is a problem that the white
cannot play h4 and this is a big problem
simply because after h4 right now there
is visual text h4 text and rook takes
itto Queen Ruby - Queen g4 and black
wins that's the big big issue here a big
problem and if not h4 then h4 comes with
the with reasonable counter play for
from black in this what happened the
game and yes what is still slightly
stuck in pattern but in the long run a
black of correctly should be equalized
that's why I was thinking that here
Queen b3 a quick view was a mistake like
inaccuracy more like that in Queen c2
was the best move Quincey to the is the
best move in mapping simply because
after h5 we can play actually h4 and
pull a bit of Texas for it not possible
because we protect twice only - and also
we can take the Queen only - let's say
this this route lazy to does Queen takes
two wins for for white and this is very
subtle of course also if this disc wins
for 93 inches wins just bees up and yes
this is very subtle but you know
sometimes is just you know small
difference make may make huge difference
small small kind of like subtlety make
can make huge difference in a long run
yeah and peer analyze princess rook a c8
quindi one because the thing is that
strategically what is much better there
is this past pawn both phones are
doubled and pawned and one of them will
make very likely fall in the future if
white can make sure that it's a king is
safe then in the future white will be
able to finally put this before Paul
maybe attack both d4 d5 point somehow
and create some winning chances but with
the way we king there will be tremendous
Condor play for black and this is the
main sort of point here so analyze group
be a rocky one for instance Bishop e7
but this position also would not be so
easy but in general I believe would be
slightly burned for white here this h4
h5 is it's a t54 it's possible but it's
a little bit worse version in the game
here already is Queens on d2 which kind
of supports also Queen side even with
the same bishop moves then we already
tried pair of roast which is in white
favor and and things like this so I
think this would this was the correct
way to play this game in this position
but it's very very subtle and maybe
maybe I'm wrong I could be also wrong
because Queen be free if h5 is not
dangerous than why would why would you
play Queen c2 it's very very tough to
say so when the phrase very natural move
and I don't want to describe it but I
can feel that quiz 2 will be little more
accurate least to me and here h5 is a
very strong move basically Black has to
look for counter play well counter play
there is no way that white can the black
can basically survive this for instance
also bodies to look for correct content
because rook a b85 idea of b6 or h6
would be a wrong type of counter play
for instance after King G to group B 6
rook a 1 which is rook age 691 there is
move 91 and covers h3 protects the King
and this one just rolls rolls forward
and it's just my winning for white so we
also black has to be careful what type
of counter play you know to pursue here
and it far is very strong move threatens
h4 and put some mating let's say Nets
around words king bee 590 G to H for
night each one was an alternative this
prophylaxis also made perfect sense
well on the other hand it would be hard
to push this beep on now for instance
Ruby 8 B 5 and Ruby 6 and group a B 8
come is coming and I'm not really sure
how to follow up here Oh fight I think
in the long run what should be black
should be equalized so King this make
perfects also sense but it's you know if
you can push the pawn and there is no
immediate threat on with h4 why would
you not push the pawn and basically
create some b6 b7 based on pattern on b7
especially after h4 b 6
you know pawns already on b6 and there
is no any clear idea
mating idea for black and in this
position from practical point of view is
very hard to play make a move of black
because the England right now made a
huge mistake
he played h3 and after h3 white is just
much better
it's just nearly nearly crushing and the
thing is that h3 limits what blacks
possibilities of creating attack yes it
free creates this sort of hope I bring
the Queen to d2 and mate somehow but
it's never going to happen if only black
white put the nitrogen one basically
cover a free square and this night does
all the defensive perfect defensive job
on under and the Polish free actually
would also be a weakness
so never will just taking h1
and kyochon is perfectly safe poetry is
just lost Nyjah one comes protects the
King as well and with the pollen v6
coming to be 7 next move
there is no any counter play for black
just wink nearly winning maybe black and
sort of sort of save it somehow but at
least I couldn't find anything that I
would be satisfied with from let's see
both sides let's say both formula so I
was trying to be objective analyzing
this and I came to the conclusion here
that actually h3 even though it's so
typical and so natural restricts blacks
possibly attacking possibilities because
sometimes it actually may be useful to
throw in HD eg free because it would
actually take a take out one of the
defenders of whites King and the line I
was analyzing for instance look a b8 and
this move if this move is positioned far
from clear I think black should be
relatively okay here for instance b7
through p7 Ruby 1 and Queen g4 right now
is hang on e2 is hanging on b7 wife has
to make sort of a decision right now how
to what - you know what to do next
another several moves and none of them
were actually persuasive to me for
instance
Queen takes d5 just route xe2 takes
takes Queen to h5 23 rooks see one I
thought was the most forced because
we've said ism is a big fresh right now
but for Queen 86 I couldn't see what
next
for instance rook c7 and h3 this right
now the spawn makes perfect sin this
poem of makes perfect sense because
Queen e1 is a fret and after a 4 just
rook e8
analyze will be same Europe d8 it's a
messy position but why why would black
be worse here thus King on G 1 is also
very weak their ideas between one queen
bee - I don't see why why this why white
would be better here
and see why because came on Japan's
right now is very exposed
another idea of our FINA analyze for
instance is Queen c2 but not xb7 rotates
be something related to these two great
conversation for black where there is
work black doesn't risk anything why
what has to be careful not to lose this
other possibility and I know it's Queen
D 1 and then for instance I was g6 and
you know some game goes on but in
general I think black should be should
be equalized at some point for instance
Queen f1 h3 right now and the king h1
already Queen f3 so it's not so easy and
it afford that which oversees this is
weakening White's King so h3 who is an
idea but it was playing a very
unfortunate moment and if rook a b8 for
instance in this voice lines with screen
g4 I don't see I don't see anything here
great for for white for instance one
last line that I willing to show queen
d1 this g6 and if Knight c3 trying to
trade the Queen's we don't trade the
quiz because we being worse surgically
want to keep attacking possibilities I
mean contracting possibilities on the
board
Ruby 6 Queen a 595 if 92 of course we
just come back at least 24 we were
normally satisfied the draw here and
could not be 5 and after right now is
already h.323 possible with one of the
example lines word h2 h3 is possible is
stronger than putting pollen age 3
because after takes
there's maybe Bishop e3 for instance
black has to go on after the white skin
to create counter play but is to be very
accurate with doing it and h3 the way
ding did it here is basically just
unfortunate because King h1 in 91 was
perfectly safe and this just nearly game
over
rookie b8 happen in the game analyze
alternatives but none of them real work
for black let's say rook a be 891 room
p7 just queen bee 5 it's hard to suggest
anything goes with trade rooks
I'm sorry trade quiz pawn is true we
just lost Ruby CA let's say rook a1 as
possible everyone is possible this is
just crushing because b7 Queen B 5 is
coming and there is nothing white black
can do because there is if you know any
counter play and if the spoon comes to
b7 and we then we trade one pair of
ropes and maybe the quiz and pollinate
trees falling pond if I was fine 24 is
weak as well
Bishop is just empty on dark squares
here and this is just really really bad
Queen a5 also 9 times e1 Queen d1 for
instance foreign Queen h5 and Queen f3
even a queen of 3 takes takes just 91
even such positions are very dangerous
because technically what is just pawn up
even though it's equal material but the
most bones are I stopped by this one and
here we have on the King side we have 3
vs 2 and the White Knight is much
stronger than bishop on p6 because it
can't really create and I mean 21st pawn
to 3 and pawn d5 would be surrounded by
a Brooke be walking G 294 OB 5 just just
winning very likely so in the game
happened rookie b8 rook FB 191 also
possible Balrog everyone's good as well
equivalent moves Bishop d8 if rugby 791
for instance if room the bishop d8 here
an apple I think made me made a mistake
because he played a visually Queen B 5
it could be 5 years it creates it I'm
crazy
fred of trading queens but in such
positions whenever you have a chance
basically put respond to b7 you should
just do it because the pollen b7 you
know there is no any counter play any
so ever for for black because let's say
who k7 just 94 rook' 591 for instance
the opponent H trees hanging I mean is
this very very weak and move over lucky
for Queen d1 queen of Oman over and
after okay 794 pound if I was hanging
and if we go for this endgame there is
no way that black can so save this
because this position should be lost
because white King is perfectly safe and
all the black spawn should eventually
drop for instance this is just King g2
and pawns will drop slowly but surely
will fall and this - I mean and
potentially in the future pawn white
will try to double on the seventh ring
and try to win f7 pawn also weak black
and white can go Ruby seven root guru b7
and then just take on f7 because even
then palanquins would be waiting for for
white so this should be just waiting for
a white in opinion and if Queen g4 for
instance we can just take the piece
because this is just by a version of all
the lines that I mentioned earlier so b7
usually when you have a chance you
should just go for it but after Queen B
Phi suddenly black has great chance to
save this game and after Queen f5 it was
basically only move it would be really
really hard for for white to to win this
and pre-collision becomes extremely
messy and actually very hard to
understand why what was the UN thinking
here because after Queen g4 you know 25
just you know takes the pawn for
instance and the stops queen of free and
like game over
also there is move like Queen yet which
is even simpler just taking this f7 pawn
and protecting from Queen a frequent on
the fight is still hanging and this is
just game over as well so it's very hard
to understand why didn't he play Queen
fi because the same idea but just
protects on d5 enough sir
it's hard to understand for me but yeah
it's hard to understand for me but also
he's hanging on v62 so and here I
analyzed various things and I never
could find equality here like you know
advantage clear advantage for why for
instance Knight takes d4 Queen g4 I will
I mean the position of rhenium becomes
extremely tactical and minuses I might
have made some mistakes but I will show
my main line that act ends in the rook
endgame which black holes by only moves
but still black holes and this is my
main line that I analyze so let's see if
they're b7r okay seven if Queen I ate
this basically is extremely unclear in
this position
we can't retake here because Queen a5 is
and b7 Queen 83 this should be the long
run rate dangerous also it may be
possible because already black is a
piece so from very practical perspective
is not so clear and after but main move
I analyzed must be seven okay seven
Queenie eight takes Queen takes Bishop
f6 Queen d4 would have led to a similar
position
but after b5 I think would be it just
just a little bit or maybe Queen at five
and Queen eight three also would be just
word version because pawns already on b7
and those rules are basically especially
at least Reuben ba this forced to stay
there to the end of the game and
whatever it goes of pawns as well so the
main analysis Bishop f6 trying to pin
here and then route before Bishop Daisy
for Quinta is d5 Ruka five takes here
rogue a5 first remove because 25 Queen
f3 rook takes d4 takes the piece back
but number of takes be suddenly huge
issues on the back rank we can take on
b7 of the rogue because okay one or
Queen D 1 after Queen takes b7 Queen
takes d4 Queenie for I thought was the
best chance
because I was asking on edge ones in
real danger maybe Quinn if free was also
possible but then rook a one I guess
could be a problem
not so clear so I think you when you're
free looking one would be a problem I
think after Queenie 4 takes takes rook a
to this is the unmanned I otherwise and
here black eventually eventually can
hold some hope but it's very very
complicated yes but it's still I
couldn't find a break for here for for
white so this was the best defense
basically play Queen a5 but you know it
leads to praise positions but from let's
say kind of like if you have to choose
between Queen g4 Queen if I was to move
because they're the most natural or
clear we have to keep Queens on the
board Queen a file was just much more
natural if you have a choice you just
have to go for it because after Queen g4
it's fairly simple therefore quinten's
if I just stops everything
Queenie question may be a little more
tactical but also stops everything of
their Queen f5 is not so clear because
94 24 certainly there are some big
issues the Queen e8 King h7 Queen f7 and
the rook taste b6 and both lines as I
said are very very crazy and eventually
as I analyze there are some drawers like
this there are some end games like this
very likely black can eventually defend
here and so but the England play Queen
g4 and suddenly after Queen takes d5
Queenie was even stronger
for instance yeah
King h7 Queen f7 let's say root X b6
takes takes a free and neither for both
all the pawns are collapsing I was just
following Queen of Queen h5 Queen h3 or
Queen takes d5 my disease is possible on
b6 this may be hanging at some point
just completely winning and about 25
also is winning group a5 and some
finally famous or infamous move Queen c6
that never played automatically which is
natural but it's a lot of you know
tactical idea that
chemist and here as it was i he
mentioned the press-conference
f3 was just very simple and there after
route 85 pawn takes rook b7 and now
let's say Ruby five hours as the most
accurate because after of d6 I the four
takes takes this position is just
complete doing there is no any doubt
about this is just winning bone up on
night of 294 is coming just resign above
sort of complete Ewing and but here this
was the the simplest of free because you
know we want to trade the quiz after
every basic enforces that Queen trade
right now for the quaintest so you can't
fault the Queen trade why not why not
and off because after quiz is
excellently there there is a brilliant
defense that was available suddenly for
black with rook takes b6 and this is
just draw which is crazy and an episode
someone who sees this should be
disqualified well I wouldn't be so hard
about it because like after it's only
move like you know you have to like at
least this create some mess and like you
know to hope sometimes for the best so
[Music]
especially at like maybe an hour or
something here it's a golf course is
completely crazy and random but you know
is the best best least practical try
throw b8 rookie 5 threaten Queenie one
mate and the root is the 8th King h7 and
right now despite being the whole rock
down there is nothing that white can do
but basically agree to a drafter okay
Jade because which one is Queen takes f2
and Rupert one is coming and suddenly
black needs to be really really careful
why this we really careful not to lose
this afternoo gauge I'd just take stakes
analyze this disc in g6 first important
move because King JRuby 8 but here King
g6 and after Queen f1 black can make a
draw in two possible ways let's say this
is what simpler than just movie totally
free draw and or maybe even Queen a free
and go for activity is also should lead
to a drop
as I checked but yeah this was brilliant
defense that doing we really missed rook
takes b6 q c5 I felt I thought that he I
think that he already thought he's just
lost years which is kinda like wanting
to end the game like you know play Russa
fathers as the last resort let's say
hope to trick Quincy for Queen III of
course never happens with Nyjah want is
just consolidating the position and this
is just came over to the game ended with
following moves and here design being
just piece down and after rotated if
possibly rube taste differently through
graphene a 95 that's the final idea but
yeah very very interesting game in my
opinion but showing also a lot of
practical choices that both sides could
have you know went for if only they had
I know I figured out what were the best
you know like practical choices here
like to say Queen at five was the very
practical decision you know no matter
what happens just go for it because
alternative energy forms as you know
losses in two possible ways like Quinn
takes the the five or Queenie eight we
have seven so yeah let's go funny to the
last game that I want to talk about and
this is mvl versus napalm energy again
the game of the palmistry and this was I
picked this game because it made mvl the
leader of the tournament he for his six
by some reason never mind she chooses to
go again for French which normally he
goes for night Dorf but he didn't switch
to French and in here in he played
already against Alexei Inca in round
number three so just see what happened
this game is classic Alvin our ninety
seven and here there's h4 played
mvl and also Alex saying earlier few
runs earlier all that moves our Queen
g49 a3 a4 and
for yeah most removes all our many
alternatives who injured for bus is the
by far the most popular move and there
is lots of theory and I'm but the
position arising there are very kind of
like tactical and I think they're very
pretty much nipples style so queen g4
would be leading to a very tactical
practical player stuff to say after
64:27 room g8 we need 727 I'm pretty
sure and oppose any forward lines
because alternatives are basically
pretty pretty
you know depressing I would say let's
say King f8 is not great in my opinion
castle is also considered as dangerous
but seat XD for Queen c7 and going for
this main line very tactical line it's
the best try for back but and we all
played h4 which is more positional
approach twisty 785 another move is not
the free and this is what was happened
in the game of our Cinco VS Naipaul
machine in round number 3 and here b6
Bishop d5 Bishop d7 we should be too if
Bishop d3 Bishop a4 would be played
Bishop e2 Bishop a4 short Castle
happened 97 Bishop e3 h6
rook a 295 and I think here an apology
easily equalized in this game very
likely Alex think wasn't expecting
French and in here he just you know went
for this position but didn't get any
advantage of Cinco and and so there is
no no therefore there was no reason for
an information not to repeat this line
against them veal right now and here I
was going to quickly show small tactical
idea that was missed by both our players
because here right now I think ok we saw
before and here an epimer she had an
idea possible idea to play Knight f6 and
in this position bit of money for it's
hanging idea comes to be for and I think
black has really really good chances to
you know win the game eventually I mean
I've quit six and position of through be
to a six the SEC v there was extremely
complicated position some mess for the
entire game eventually and draw but this
is not the topic of today's lecture just
going to show like what happened this
game in the opening because right now
and feel improved with h5 h6 and now
know the phrase would be also possible
but the thing is that here is the
classical line let's say Bishop a4 short
Castle c4 Bishop e2 96 and there is this
classical idea here I think from Arthur
you support from I know what tournament
but like it's so well known that I just
I couldn't help myself but to show it
basically let's say Knight age for a
short long castle and right now very
often the Queen comes here and black
drinks the Queen to h7 hits on c2 and
Bishop on e4 is also very well placed
and then black prepares also a break
from the Kings side it's also possible
to play rook the g8 immediately and then
g5
but this idea of Quincy bring the Queen
to e7 it's very classical and I just
want to show it quickly and that's the
reason why I'm pressured never want goes
over something like this but that's the
problem Bishop e5 Knight f3 move right
now never play Ruby one which is much
more flexible
it's very idea first place by Pat peter
lacquer in 2015 against Aleksei Gorin
off in World Cup but this idea is much
more flexible because it's top CD CD
because after Quincy Friedrich on a ones
don't hang anymore who can play just
Queen d2 for instance also Bishop one
sacrifice would be also interesting but
Queen e2 is at least what what can do
and after here there is some choice for
instance in the game of Peter Lajos 96
Quincy for who
therefore very flexible because it keeps
an option of queen g4 for the future and
it doesn't necessarily mean that I would
go to Africa sometimes an icon go to ito
as well see we'll have in this game but
let's quickly see echoes game a Quincy
495 Bishop d3 CD CD 94 Bishop b2 humans
game very convincingly Queen a5
possibility position is already very bad
quiz 5 Matthew a little bit more
accurate but 25 was in the game after
this these days his position was just
overwhelming just crushing just wife
black has no development why this always
just simply winning position in my
opinion
thank you one eventually very nicely
so let's come back to this position now
populate b6 a Quincy for Ruby g8 rare
but again they played very very quickly
this move from as minimal preparation
alternatives are CD and King f8 I'm not
really sure whether they are great for
instance CD Queen g7 25 white can I
think be better after either 92 or kindy
1 that's a 92 with the CBO before let's
say Queen f5 and the free analyze
something like this and we should be 5
with better position for widest pwnage
file is extremely strong and you just
you know bring the Queen and point goes
to h7 I'd rate and that's it of course
black Eskander played there is some
tactic very tactical position but in
general I believe why should we bother
also there is move King do one here
which also should give some advantage in
this endgame if we don't want to go for
very anything tactical King f8 usually
you doesn't sound doesn't doesn't look
good if this is not developed yet there
is idea of a true f3 and it's becoming
greedy dangerous in my opinion ruby
happened in the game
Bishop b5 right now this move makes
perfect sense because after Bishop d7
Bishop d3 there are these ideas of
Bishop age 7 so after c4 bishop h7 a
white just ways and
before is not really coming you know
this is us in the game of against Alex
Cinco for instance so he ran a public
kinga fight we should be free Bishop
eight six and here it was the first one
that he actually spent some time
alternative was these days the four
stakes before Bishop a six takes takes
quindi one rook c8 let's say in rugby
too
and this is very interesting position
because evaluation of this position in
my opinion depends on the player like it
made some weird as when I say it but
that's what I believe because with why
players were white very often believe
that what is much better or like just
maybe done much better but better or
have better chances simply because this
King gone away it is misplaced and there
are possibilities of explaining on the
King side may be threatening to attack
on f7 somehow maybe on g7 maybe play d4
g5 at some point maybe f4 f5 at some
point but and try to ignore let's say
blacks activity on the Queen side on the
other hand players who like this
position of black like you know
dispositions simply because all the
light scores that are
week right now and they can be exploited
so we've done beard net see 695 maneuver
and hoping to bring this kink to let's
say to discern maybe somehow player okay
Jake injecting age seven sometimes make
this King safe maybe play for f6 at some
point so it's if the is that it's about
Abu who who is better
personally I feel like what should be
brother but from a practical game
anything can happen but it's very very
complex position and it's you know it
depends on many many let's say beside
kind of like chests you know factors and
how to assess this position basically
like style of play of the players and so
on all everything like these matters
because you know a style of play like
mood you know things like this really
matter here because if then the person
who plays you know very aggressive chest
will prefer why because we'll just go
for me let's say windows 923 a shortcut
for a five and just made somehow but
player was very good positional chest
may struggle here why well an excel with
black so it's kind of like debatable but
never the same play Bishop basics I
guess that he assumed that position of
their states for his Wars which was my
impression but I would if that we would
have asked him and here this Bishop a6
has this drawback that it allows the
text c5 and also plays very quickly by
MVL the problem is after Bishop with the
idea is after Bishop takes the free
steaks the free 97 d4 64 and right now
we're it's time of Queen d1 and the
Queen has done its job on g4 and just
can easily come back to d1 and the
position is very similar to what we had
earlier let's say who the pound beast b7
or b6
but the thing is the runner-up on c5 the
B file is opened so if anything this
would be better version I think for
wider than for blah
but you know it's again debatable this
creates some more let's say
possibilities to place a trade some
pawns on before maybe open C files
before open C file for while like Queen
its develop oh it's very hard to assess
but the thing is that after Queen d1
what is there was very strong move
because queen is done a job already on
g4 probably say King Ruby Jean King f8
and right now why was simply play 92
short Castle f4 f5 and just made on the
King side and this is sort of what
happened in the game
let's but let's look at the alternative
after a 65 nap occupy Queen takes d5
because you know why it seems the very
natural just grab this if five pound is
just with central pawn and after 92
Bishop takes the frist XD free try to
you know I play this position because
you know it seems like if black can cut
the central pawn on e5 it should solve
some at least some portion of problems
here after a BTech c5 to be sure before
ways because design is just lost here
from this rogue and Bishop just show it
quickly and after night so many sevens
is a forced move and Here I am allies
see takes b6 it takes b6 Queen before
King yet and and the I was wondering
what this position and to be honest it
doesn't look clear to me at all and I
believe that if I would be playing this
I'll rather be content with this
position rather than the one in the game
because here at least there are some
possibilities to create maybe the center
of those pawns
let's say maybe I should put green
because I'll try to show the strength
maybe to play the same room the Queen
from if I play e5
maybe trade quiz somehow and black has
little better structure has issues the
King but let's say in the long run maybe
there are some chances for black
of the with the idea of creating the
center and basically try to you know
hope for some good end games there if we
can trade a Queens but as I analyzed I
think what is still by also move a king
of one for instance because we can't
castle but we want to get out of the pin
on the Queen only five think of one and
I seasoned Queen three four let's say we
won't keep Queens on the board and the
same be sure before becoming maybe row
gauge free maybe c4 trying to play
against the skin Ghani seven Cokie money
age and I think what is slightly better
here but this was the correct them the
better way to played an approach this
position in my opinion at least there is
something to hope for
unlike in this position with the King on
f8 I don't really see a plan here for
black and napal collapse very very
quickly in the pre in the other position
I think it would be much better chance
for him to you know create some mess
because here and VL just played
brilliantly and then give Napo any
chances so let's see what happened Queen
eight five
I've in case of Ruby eight to be take
stakes and ninety-two phrase and short
castle imported to develop isn't we to
again because short castle f4 maybe g4f
five or nine g3 f5 design really belongs
to doesn't be locked with free bribe
belongs to e to or supports policy free
and has some is blood more flexible and
Queenie five company in the game Bishop
d2 Ruby eight a queen III
doesn't really matter this phone just go
editor short Castle the same plan a king
of Nevada is a weakness spawn if it
doesn't really matter so here you should
black I mean never played rugby eight
which is correct ninety-two correct
metaphor was also possible but I really
like 92 because this idea of castle and
just going towards a five is very
persuasive to me and right now I think
never played horrible move after which
the process position is nearly nearly
lost for this
practical and strategical point of view
because he played here c4 and this move
is horrible simply it's very ambitious
because you know tries to be in some
space maybe try to show this Bishop on
the - it's a week and come empty doesn't
do anything and hoping to basically tray
rubies on a B file and trade quiz maybe
you'll make a weakness but it just
doesn't work it's just too slow it
doesn't work doesn't just doesn't simply
work and therefore the best would I
think the best approach here for black
was to play route xb1 Queen takes pawn
in Queen a6
prophylaxis with this prophylactic on
move black can list them proudly stop
white from castling put some pressure on
I don't need to and let's say energy
free if the energy Frieda and Casso is
not possible anymore if castle and Quint
éxito not so easy and here I was
thinking that a four would be really
good try for white also a free would be
possible but I'm not really sure what
happens after let's say rookie Jade
because connection sometimes could be an
issue can give 296 G for King g7
suddenly black is alive
Ruby ed is coming son this pawn a4 a5
break 4 is not coming and g5 is not so
dangerous either I'm mapping you can
just ignore it and suddenly rook b8 and
there is some counter play so i fathered
a for be the best let's say attempt here
for for white to proceed after a for
let's say King yet I was thinking and
then if Queen one of the other thing is
king yet but then Queen b5 takes takes
this endgame would be with advantage for
white simply because we should be
freaking d2 okay one is a plan and 27 is
a weakness this rook if this rook was
let's say here on a 8 or be a door
somewhere here on the Queen side would
be back would be fine
well Budokan g8 and is not coming so
easily to the Queen side what is just
simply faster even though it's only Roby
still on a king side but just we should
be freaking the too short I mean do k1
or even short castle
okay one who's just crushing or just
crushing and the alternatives I look to
look at also where for instance Queen a
for but then we just go Castle again
don't care about this pawn Ruby one
prepared 9 G 3 and a 4 a 5 even though
we have only one basically to prepare it
Nyjah crafting is also possible c4 is
also even possible I think this pawn
doesn't really matter and f6 is possible
by the sort of weakens the King but
maybe this is also the way to play some
Knight f4 or Queen b5 thinking Esther at
least there is some you know counter
play mean we did text e5 is correct but
linking f7 suddenly is not so clear so
this was maybe the best defense let's
say a play of 6 at some point maybe also
take on d4 and CD f6 but then Knight
takes d4 has to be considered so it's
not so easy for position for for black
to play but anyway this was the only
sort of reasonable and acceptable from
my opinion way to continue here with
black because after at least here
why doesn't castle so easily and
relative to what happen in the game this
would still like a fight so in the game
what happened was c4 and this is just
possibly just lost position or nearly
lost because after short Castle Queen
Ruby 6 happened Rob Kinkade route before
doesn't really change anything if takes
takes Knight b6 we can even go Queen
before and if Queen before we can just
take your ok 1 again b5 Bishop anyone
bishops one who should be free it's
coming
strategically just horrible position for
for black the game happen it will be six
Kweisi - okay Jade protecting from Queen
h7 in any case in the future well just
you know a for preparing basically
maneuver bishops Wamba should be free
King GA finally trying to make sure that
something's you know the things with the
King are relatively okay and we operate
before 96 possibly the Bluebird
Melbourne move was not be a denied bc6
but after let's say G four days this and
the four I was thinking that this
position is just very dangerous at five
is coming and if black tries five itself
themselves I mean takes takes a five
let's say a five
kingi coup and therefore this is just
much better for it
simply as white I mean black doesn't
have rifo up nice nice they have nice
center of pawns if I've defied but
they're already follow-up no really
follow because if or would weaken a
Foursquare and the ninety-four would
follow white can play back I never want
to pluck can never take on d4 because
just Knight takes d4 or even City XD 494
then also why wants to play Ruby one and
the room p5 so this looks and if Ruby
Jade we can also play King aged three
and ponies ages would be also because
till the end of the game so this looks
pretty bad in my opinion
ninety-six was an alternative and I mean
this is what Nepal did but right now I
really like Nepal mvs approach because
right now at four we can just even
ignore this exchange positional exchange
sacrifice in this period of Tigran
Petrosian from our world champion and
takes takes Queen e6 b5 Queen b7 f5 for
instance this is just crushing Bishop
before it's coming and by the forest
coming of takes the six is coming Polly
my people in positions just around to be
simply lost for for black so
neppo just didn't sign to admit the
ninety-six wasn't the best idea and said
to come back nine seven but this is just
lost after
look everyone for instance and the rest
day of the game is just kind of like
very nice technique by MVL and there is
nothing that M neppo could do here so f5
happened Ruby 5 also a bishop Swan was
possible bring this bit of play free but
Ruby 5 with the same idea
Bishop c1 looking at CERN which obey
free Ruby 8 takes only 7 good decision
simply because after this night almost
protecting this I mean support is pawn
at 5
but after takes d4 white simply opens
the kingside and this is just came over
rook takes d5 takes takes everything
takes on a 5 Ruby one Queen B 1 and this
is just collapsing because after it
takes 5 9 3 3 & 4 & 5 collapses after
Queen b6 Queen c2 we can just play like
here maybe even take Patos we can take
King f2 and then Geoffrey cars coming
and pawn if I was just lost position
just simply lost here for 4 for
diplomacy and after takes Queen 93 they
came and that very nicely for mvl Queen
e1 nice technique
93 no any counter play I came she took
in a for Queen 87 there's only one check
on the top available which doesn't
really matter 26 centralizing the Queen
g5 happen if kindy to just king h3 he
think this you know fret also I mean
will be afraid the Queen moves around a
425 also just wins the pawn and after g5
takes h5 trying to let's say complicate
things with h4 maybe or whatever but
just g7 and here neppo decided to resign
very interesting game the most important
part of this game I think was the
opening because the up in the opening
the open in the opening Napo made some
questionable choices
first of all I'm not sure whether this
choice of French opening was correct in
such important game it was better maybe
to stay true to yourself I mean of
course the battable right now and these
two we see from the perspective of the
you know you know when not playing by
analyzing being be comfortable
comfortable now I'm now I think this at
home and but maybe French wasn't the
best opening to choose for this game
simply because it's very risky
strategically opening and this is we've
seen in this game that
Napo had really big problems in this
game especially at some only based c4
especially just collapses it's difficult
to imagine after we move like before and
move number 20 or whatever it was
positions just lost so maybe it was
birth pain either but or maybe just play
some something else in this French you
know it's difficult to say right now but
never does and we all played brilliant
game showed great preparation even
though he only like I know 10 days to
prepare for the entire tournament
I mean pretty proper who's preparing for
this tournament entire life and so on
but anyway it was anyway impressive
opening preparation by him and I think
we learned personally I learned to very
you know like interesting things in the
French opening in this vinegar line and
who knows ma'am I'm using myself with
white or black because we from Bach's
perspective also I learned personally
that you know it's okay to I mean what
to avoid and what to aim for as well so
yeah very interesting stuff in this
candidate and I'm personally looking for
the second portion we'll see how the
situation results are around a more
reserved but hopefully no one will be
I know hopefully will end in positive in
positive way so that's all I have and
thank you for today
and see you see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]